In Japan, Fumio Kishida has formally taken over as prime minister.
The 64-year-old easily won Monday's parliamentary vote to become the country's new leader.
He succeeds Yoshihide Suga, who stepped down after only one year in office.
Kishida is expected to dissolve parliament and call a snap election for November later this week.
Observers see the early date as a move to take advantage of his fresh image.
Kishida will face several tough issues including Japan's post-pandemic economic recovery...
...and a nuclear-armed North Korea.
A former foreign minister, Kishida was regarded until recently as a moderate liberal,...
...but has apparently shifted to the right in a bid to win over influential conservatives...
...in his Liberal Democratic Party.